measures aim to tackle radical as
proposed by the government are engulfed
in debate in the Netherlands
humanitarian aid groups are speaking out
against the reach of a proposed counter
terrible which focuses on global hot
spots
they say they should be exempt from it
in order to freely continue their work
in war zones now they proposed bill will
designate certain zones as terrorist
areas from then on it will be illegal to
be present in such areas without
permission the Netherlands already has
laws that criminalize taking part in
terrorist activities abroad but agencies
now fear a prosecution for their
humanitarian activities without a
specific exemption from the law for aid
workers it's an attempt to outlaw
citizens of a country going to a place
and become terrorist and become foreign
fighters for terrorist organizations
what is my concern as an aid worker
is that there is no humanitarian
exemption so even my colleagues who are
aid workers who need to go to places
where there are listed terrorist groups
to help the victims of terror can then
be out Lord well an amendment to exempt
humanitarian workers along with
journalists was suggested but that was
blocked in Parliament's because of legal
uncertainty surrounding the definition
of those professions the Christian
Democratic appeal of a party has been
seeking clarification on how to define
their working journalists for me
vlogging jihadist while according to the
People's Party for freedom and democracy
not all aid groups can be trusted well
we've been getting reaction to this
including from freelance journalist Luke
Ravi and young Eggland's from the
Norwegian Refugee Council the laws are
not necessarily needed because nearly
all countries have lost outlawing
terrorism and to become a terrorist to
go to outlaw existence in visiting an
area there are under terrorist rule is
one step too far the problem is that
humanitarian workers believed our super
hero
but they are not that just normal like
everybody else and so you have among
them people who can radicalize easily
and who can be very dangerous who can be
career who can do things I don't say it
is a majority at all you know but these
things can happen and it is normal that
people coming back from these zones
which are forbidden to Westerners are
screened when they come back the whole
purpose of Terror is to scare us to
terrorize us so what the
parliamentarians do is that they enact
very wide reaching laws the more the
tougher the law the better it is in the
fight against terror they think it is
important that such laws exist in
Western Europe for the people who go to
these zones and who come back who can be
dangerous when they come back especially
now that we see that in Syria the
Turkish offensive makes it that there
are many escapes among jihadists from
prisons or from camps and places if you
come from this region we want the police
discreetly that's all we need to be
there because there is where the victims
of violence are we need to have a go
ahead we need to have access to those
area and these laws are holding us back
we need humanitarian exemptions to all
of these laws there is a problem it
seems for humanitarian NGOs the
non-governmental organizations because
they don't want to be controlled they
say we are above the fray we shouldn't
be controlled neither should academics
or journalists who go to these zones and
are the members of parliament and the
netherlands in the hague if said no we
disagree with you we want to impose it
you